what's up man this is a mortal technique
Harlem New York I'm here in La uh you
can check me out on the bootleg cab
podcast you already know what it is baby
peace
all right man bootleg cat podcast we got
a special guest in here a legend
Immortal Technique is here thank you sir
thank you for having me on the show of
course man I first discovered your music
I want to say I was probably like 14 or
15.
um it might have been the first
revolutionary but I remember then I got
to see you live in Phoenix
it might have been the Revolutionary
Volume 2 tour who'd you have on tour
with you around that time probably
poison pen maybe Chino XL a few other
cats yes I got to see you live and I saw
I've seen I mean I've seen you live a
bunch of times uh over the years
um but yeah man you're an independent
I would say like a goat in the
independent hip-hop space man thank you
there's not a lot of people who could be
like yeah headlined festivals is an
independent rapper and I remember seeing
you headline Rock The Bells rock the
bells pay dude's one of those I mean I
hold the record for some festivals for
UTA for my old agency at United Talent
uh we did four festivals sorry three
festivals and three different European
countries which were nowhere near each
other within a 24-hour period wow I used
to do probably about 200 250 shows a
year now obviously it's a lot less
because I have other responsibilities
but unlike other artists who you know no
disrespect to the DJ of course focused a
lot on mixtapes right I focused a lot on
touring rather than mixtape so I may
only have like one or two free mixtapes
but at the same time I have like 17
world tours under my belt right
countries that people are like oh my God
you've been to Australia Tasmania right
New Zealand all these places Romania
right you Czech Republic South America
all over the place Morocco Africa yeah
now you're worldwide dude I mean your
music I feel like your music was very
like
you know I feel like I learned so much
from your music as a kid because it was
before I really had like readily like
internet access if that makes sense so
like some of the [ __ ] like about like
our government or just the world like I
have first heard like you rapping about
it
do you hear that a lot I mean I think it
was during a time in which people were
um living in a post 9 11 world that was
really fresh and a lot of individuals
were scared they were looking for easy
answers looking for ways to blame people
and when I brought up things like for
example that I made a post today because
it's the 20-year anniversary of Senator
wellstone's uh death in a mysterious
plane crash and he was one of the only
Senators after 9 11 that brought up the
fact that Bin Laden was a CIA asset that
was not something people wanted to
discuss in 2000 right right that is code
name and this is not a conspiracy no
it's not a conspiracy it's true his code
name was Timothy Osmond and that he
carried out several acts and atrocities
um in the name of the United States
government for their purposes but not
just that also talking to people in
Afghanistan when I went there he was
responsible and took part in what they
call the hazard genocide which is
something that is going on now with the
Taliban and that's a series of Asiatic
um Central Asian
um people from Afghanistan yeah and they
were targeted for genocide so before Bin
Laden ever killed any Americans he
murdered children outside of a city
called mazara Sharif and wow like I went
to Afghanistan in 2009 to build an
orphanage in a school with the prophets
from uh an album that I had called the
third world with DJ Green Lantern shout
out to my brother Green Lantern I
remember that yeah thank you for helping
me with that Green Lantern he was
somebody that believed in me
um and brought me up to the radio even
when they were like don't bring him the
[ __ ] up to hot 97. now they're like oh
he's a legend but before they're like
don't bring him up here he's crazy I
remember when you guys linked up because
Green Lantern had kind of been like
heavily associated with like you know
the that mixtape era rocking with Eminem
and then you guys come together it was
kind of like dope because obviously
perception wise as a kid
you don't I didn't associate a Green
Lantern and Immortal even though it
makes sense like musically and it was
dope but yeah I think it like like you
said like you pointed out so much stuff
early because again at that time we
didn't have access to YouTube and like
jumping down a rabbit hole and it's like
wait a minute what is he talking about
like you know I think um
I think that you definitely uh you know
in terms of
shedding the light to a whole generation
of kids who are just hip-hop heads you
definitely did open their eyes to a lot
of wild shipment and a lot of truthful
[ __ ] right and also I think that even to
this day there's songs that I've written
that people still ask me questions about
like I'm not gonna lie Kev even 20 years
later people ask me is Dance with the
Devil a true story and I have to look
these people right in the eye and say
sir I am not responsible for raping or
killing any women that is absolutely
crazy it is a song however yeah I can
take people if they really want to the
building where this incident happened in
Harlem and the truth is that that
actually did happen and those people
that were allegedly responsible for that
began dying and that's why it became
such a powerful story because everyone's
like oh you're telling Hood Tales what
if these [ __ ] come back for you
and I said let them right what they
gonna do like you think that the
neighborhood is going to protect them
after they find out what they really did
that they raped a woman do you realize
that in rich communities you can get
away with stuff like that oh they're
little kids coming in all hours in the
night no one says anything they're all
billionaires but if you live in the
ghetto and someone says a rumor in the
hood oh someone's touching kids in
apartments
everybody from the neighborhood
so that's the kind of energy it was and
these people literally started dying and
one of them
I I we're not going to mention names
because these people don't deserve to be
remembered in a good light but this is a
sad story they couldn't find this man
and I what I explained to people about
the street is that there's no there's no
rules just like there's no such thing as
a safe gun you have to respect
everything I'm a big Second Amendment
guy you have to respect the weapon
there's no such thing as a safe gun
these people were out here thinking that
they could get away with a crime and
that they wouldn't be found and they
murdered this man's son to get him to
come to the funeral so they could kill
him
this is the type of [ __ ] that people
were dealing with that's one of your
would you say that your most popular
song it's like one of them right
probably yeah um for people who because
there's gonna be people watching this
YouTube video who subscribe who who
maybe are not hip to your catalog give
us a break like for people who haven't
heard Dance with the Devil what is the
premise of the record well I mean
without giving the entire thing away I
would say that
um it's definitely a very realistic tale
of what happens when people feel peer
pressured to commit violence to join a
gang or when they feel like they have to
overcompensate for not being as tough as
everybody thinks they is and they commit
violence and do horrible things to
people to try to prove something to
somebody I remind individuals that are
really living in the street we don't
deal with gratuitous violence we deal
with people that have offended or hurt
us who have come into our neighborhood
and cause problems the premise of going
into another neighborhood and just
trying to hurt people right doesn't make
sense now I mean even if you ask the
essays that run each Block they'll be
like why would I start a war for no
reason but in New York City it was
structured differently it wasn't so much
gangs it was Crews back in New York
right right so if you heard about a
story like this it became an urban
legend immediately and not just that Kev
it was that
the story was always a little bit
different instead of it being the guy's
mom it would be the person's stepsister
it would be the aunt it would be someone
related and I think when you have tales
about you know Murder or killing people
it's a grandized some sometimes in
hip-hop to the point that you never
really see the impact of what that is
like even if y'all kill someone that's
not a kid if y'all kill someone that's
30 years old you think that's not
somebody's son of course you don't think
you have a Target on your back right you
don't think that somebody's coming back
for you that's the reality then and more
often than not when people come up to me
and they say oh do you think the guys
from Dance with the Devil were really
cursed by the devil and I'm like no they
lived a horrible lifestyle where they
thought they could get away with hurting
people at random and eventually it
catches up not just to them but to their
children as well um yeah that's some
real [ __ ] you had uh so many records
that were controversial did you ever
like feel any pressure from like outside
entities when you were touring because
obviously you were you were kind of like
one of the few people I would say pre
you because I kind of attribute like
YouTube to
helping with a lot of people's education
on certain situations because it's free
and it's readily available right and I
feel like when you first kind of uh came
on the scene that wasn't necessarily the
case did you get any blowback from like
the government or did you ever have like
like a Target on your back in terms of
like just some of the things you were
talking about especially to the youth
post 911 you know what I mean I've had
several incidents where police have come
to my house uh Homeland Security I
didn't become a citizen until I was 17
so they brought an ice officer with them
as if that was supposed to intimidate me
right but an individual such as myself
is lawyered up the Wazoo yeah
like listen I can't fight the system by
shooting back at them that's what they
want yeah I mean I'm unless I'm I'm
ready to go full Chris Dorner right rest
in peace but if I am sitting there
trying to
get my point across and I don't want to
be censored or I don't want people to
control that aspect of the music then
sure I have to take those precautionary
measures ahead of time of whatever I do
I think being mature enough to look back
as a kid and know hey man these are some
of the mistakes I made these are things
I could have done better they're things
I would have done differently now like
honestly I'm doing it 100 alone now I'm
even more independent than I was before
everything is now Rebel Army records and
just straight Immortal Technique and
then I built a 501c3
um that we modeled after the Black
Panther breakfast party program to be
part and linked to that label it's
called Rebel Army runs and you can find
us that's a charity right yeah 501c3
just so people don't know yeah it's a
charity um you can find us on the
internet at Rebel Army runs and
basically you remember the projects you
were talking about we've been to just
about every project in Manhattan and now
we're expanding to Brooklyn
um where we give away a two-week food
pack to the seniors through that um
through their community centers and
through the that nycha housing programs
directly and I just want to point out to
people that didn't know that in New York
City right during the pandemic they
canceled 14 food programs for people
they couldn't afford to feed those
people and we actually became the
functional food program for the Dyckman
houses for the grand houses which were
surfaced this morning by my team when I
wasn't there you can see the posts right
now big shout out to my brother Thanos
and uh the little short a little
Dominican shorty Gene that came and took
my place because I do it myself when I'm
not doing a series of other things wow
so it's been a joy to be able to do that
and we've we're proud to say that um all
donations are are now tax deductible
because of our 501c3 status and we've
passed the mark where we fed over 10 000
families and when I say a two-week food
pack I mean we give them like four to
the three four more cases of um of tuna
then we have a two week oatmeal pack we
have canned milk we have raviolis we
give them like tomato paste we get them
pasta and then we like to have soups in
there and then we give away ensure for
the elders and we have also Pedialyte
and Pampers wow and they have feminine
products as well so I always tell people
Revolution isn't sexy you know what I
mean it's not just about having a beret
and running around the jungle with a gun
you got to get your hands dirty and help
people and it's not always easy you know
well I think too like that's I think
that's important to point out because so
many artists that I grew up listening to
around that same era who I guess were
probably perceive this conscious rappers
and I I don't know if I consider you a
conscious rapper as much as like a
reality art but you know back in that
day there was like the conscious rap
thing and a lot of those guys didn't put
their money where their mouth was I
guess you know what I mean in terms of
like it gets dope to see 20 years later
you're just fighting the good fight man
right fighting to fight for your people
I I can't speak to other people but what
I can say is this I could say that
because my life was personally affected
by these things
um I wanted to contribute back like for
example for the people that don't know
um I went to I got locked up when I was
a kid I spent my 21st birthday being
incarcerated in the hole and when I got
out I thought one of the things that I
could do is teach at a school and what
we did is myself and a young lady named
Carmen Perez
um I met the great Harry Belafonte wow
Harry Belafonte and he said you know you
have such a way with words would you
consider being a teacher in one of these
school programs so Harry Belafonte okay
gave me my first teaching job and I
taught at a school called Horizons so it
was interesting because at the time I
was still kind of touring this album
called the Martyr which did great like
four million downloads everything was
wonderful we turned the world but after
like the tours were over I had the
the really kind of painful but joyful
reality of bringing this right Workshop
which was called confronting trauma
through writing to the kids and the
stories that they wrote were not just
uplifting but they were also
heartbreaking I can imagine sometimes
you feel like you need to shower
afterwards because you realize how much
suffering these kids have been through
and then again to bring it back to your
other point
those kids those Hood kids they are the
real underground right like you talk
about the Backpackers yeah they had guns
and knives in that backpack and they had
[ __ ] that they stole from the polo store
the underground shout out to the low
heads man the underground kids are the
people that make up the cruise of all of
the major label rappers right so while
y'all are praising them and acting like
they're the hardest people in the world
the reason that they're in the position
that they are is because they're backed
by the underground independent people
that are in these neighborhoods right
now you would think that applies to just
one of them no it applies to all of them
right and I feel like in in my
particular situation
um any neighborhood or any City that
I've come in I've always approached them
with such love and respect that I've
gotten nothing but that in return so
whether I'm in Detroit I got fam out
there yeah whether I'm in Miami and in
La I'm home like half my family moved
out here when we came from South America
in 1984 and you know they married into
Mexican families from Oxnard and also
from Inglewood so we've had our family
be here for years right now we get
together we have arguments about whose
food is better peruvians or Mexicans
whose pyramids are nicer ours but I
think that it's nice to have that kind
of camaraderie and I will say this Kev
it's sad for me to see artists come out
here and die or get hurt and raw because
yeah I've oh I've never felt unwelcome
here brother I've never felt that and
maybe it's just because of the way I
move and I don't call it checking in
because I'm not paying people for
protection right I'm coming if some of
the brothers or the essays asked me hey
man we're doing a kids program like uh
for example sick jacking and a hood
Santa and then my homie sleeps the the
artist incredible dude they did this um
they did this workshop for kids where
they brought a bunch of different
neighborhoods together from East Lowes
from other places to do art workshops I
was a pleasure to join that and I don't
charge people for appearances I'm like
yo man let me just come there whatever I
can do to offer and lend my voice to
this is something that we need you know
at some point somebody's got to be the
adult in the room Kim hey what up y'all
bootleg cab gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our newest sponsor man
shout out to the homies at hardean Las
Vegas that's right the number one
dispensary in the whole state of Nevada
let alone in the whole [ __ ] country
so many choices of Premium cannabis
ladies and gentlemen it is like how can
I put this you walk into it you go to
Jardin in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg have sent me
they're gonna take care of you at
hardean when I say selection I mean
selection of the best premium cannabis
in the world the best dispensary there's
a reason why hardeen is world famous
follow them right now Harding underscore
Las Vegas go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview yeah I
think two-man La is it's it's a unique
place because of how uh the unemployment
stimulated people's pockets during covid
probably more than anywhere else and
once that went away I think people a lot
of people who weren't used to living a
certain lifestyle right they got a taste
of that lifestyle and um
and you know they're trying to keep that
I mean once you get a taste of having
that real money because there was people
eating off PPP right and and the EDD out
here
um so also too like you know I think a
lot of the obviously you know there's
people who are just
wrong place wrong time I think another
thing is is like kind of being just
self-aware of where you're at
are you gonna walk around with a hundred
thousand dollars around your neck when
somebody's starving right I mean you got
to kind of like understand like the
climate that's going on in LA right now
it's crazy because I used to feel like
when I'd go to New York I'd be like you
know New York is the place where you get
jacked and I'm not saying it still isn't
of course it is but I feel like La feels
like just a much more dangerous place
now even just going to New York we were
just like man it's so nice there's not
that many homeless people like there's
homeless people obviously we saw a bunch
but like certain areas of La it's like
it's like Skid Row all over but there
are Skid Row places in New York I'm sure
there are I'll take you there next yeah
I'm sure no I'm sure and and every city
has that right but I was we were all
over the city like if you just drive
around La which I'm sure you've seen
it doesn't matter if you're in Skid Row
there's just 30 tents on the side of the
road there's like I mean but but you
guys don't have a subway system that
people live in this is true that's what
we have too nah that's true the subway
system is a whole nother variable we
have people that live underground as a
matter of fact years ago there was a
movie uh made called the mole men and it
was a documentary about people and I
would tell you myself one of the
craziest experiences I've ever had is I
was 17 and I used to run with a bunch of
wild Dominican [ __ ] I mean talk
about cutting slicing get the [ __ ] out
of the way when you've seen all 30 of us
and one day we were writing graffiti at
a place called
um the freedom tunnels which is on 72nd
Street it's all gentrified now but I
walk down the freedom Tunnel right and
when we were leaving we saw a dude just
coming out looking like [ __ ] like a like
a regular homeless dude yeah all [ __ ]
up yo and he had a plastic bag with him
right Kev he goes to one of the like the
the little fountains he washes himself
off Kev he takes out a hand towel and
uses it like a regular towel he puts on
a button-up shirt smacks on a name tag
puts a hat goes to work and gets ready
to go to work and we approached him
because I was like yo I want to ask this
[ __ ] something so we approached
him and he at first was like all right
you've seen 20 30 Dominican yeah he
thought he was gonna he was gonna victim
right and I said yo yo we don't want to
do nothing to you bro I said I just want
to ask you something and he was like
what's up and I said you really living
in in the train tunnels he said yeah
there's 150 people down there now he's
like I'm one of the people that lives
there with my wife
and I said they got that in Vegas too so
there's like a whole city of people
underneath Las Vegas right so when I
asked him this I said wait a minute you
live with your wife down there and then
you guys and she's like yeah she has a
job as a waitress and I have a job
working at this spot where I like you
know like a floor helper or whatever and
you know what that day I'm sitting in
the park with all my people's a small
while and now I'm just smoking out
thinking and I'm like
and they're like what's wrong and I'm
like you know that dude we ran into
and they were like yeah I said he's
doing better than me and they were like
what the [ __ ] you talking about he's
homeless I said no no no
no
I asked the guy before we left I said
what's what's the goal he said you know
we can save up some money and then me
and my wife in like a few years we can
move out of there and we can try and get
our own place again get back on our feet
and I looked at the guys and I said
don't you understand bro y'all
[ __ ] out here looking for for
random broads this [ __ ] not only
found the love of his life but he found
a woman that really holds that standard
For Better or For Worse and not only
that yeah but y'all [ __ ] don't
got a plan got a plan yeah and I sat
there and I was like I don't got a plan
and I don't gotta ride or die
right what the [ __ ] am I doing right I
still live with my mom and dad I'm still
I'm still I'm still with a life
preserver on right this dude's swimming
in the ocean with wifey trying to make
it and it humbled me so much that I I
swear I have a such a a different
attitude dealing with people I talked to
a janitor the way I would talk I think
everybody should do that man right
because you never know like I always
tell that to people I'm like man you
never know who you especially you know
outside of just day-to-day real life
like I talked to Young Artists all the
time about just like treating the end
you got to treat the interns with
respect you gotta treat the engineers
with respect because you never know
who's gonna end up being the president
of your label one day or you know
whoever so yeah no that's definitely the
case even like up and coming artists you
know a lot of times people [ __ ] like
well [ __ ] on up and coming artists like
it's like that could be the next whoever
the [ __ ] right they might or they'll
just go at the youth because they're
like I don't like this style or
something like that so I I know that
being from my era everybody when the
when the skinny jeans first came out
they were ripping these kids and I used
to joke with everybody I used to be like
listen
they might be wearing skinny jeans they
might even have a purse on but there's a
gun in that purse you got to be careful
with these little kids like you can't
just smack them up like there's nothing
you have to respect the fact that the
youth still they want to prove
themselves in something and so you know
whether people make fun of them here
like the Edgars at Knott's Berry Farm
you don't want to get jumped by 50 or
you're tapped into the Edgars you don't
want to get jumped listen fam
don't get jumped by 50 Edgars at Knott's
Berry Farm because that is not that's
not something that your your reputation
can recover from all right you're
getting beat up by gang members people
like all right what do you expect you
but you're getting jumped by children
don't do that you follow all the like
food communities and like all those IG
Pages who's going wild yeah big shout
out to Fool's going wild yeah yeah it
could be hilarious I think that but they
always have the Edgars fighting in knots
it's always a thing what's going on in
Knott's Berry Farm they like had to
change the rules yeah they made it so
that you have to have a big homie with
you but that didn't change that much
because I could just get the 20 year old
homie to come right right so you have to
be accompanied by someone over 21. yeah
so you just got to bring the big homie
now uh what it was your because
obviously uh I think that we just went
through a pretty wild historical time
with the pandemic
um
I think that a lot of the people who
question the vaccine are probably like
feeling a little more Vindicated of
recent recent memory but uh from your
perspective someone who's always kind of
spoken about big government and just
[ __ ] you know I what was your thought
process now that we're kind of removed I
wouldn't say we're totally removed right
but now that we've kind of gotten
through this pandemic the the vaccine
just all that it was kind of a weird era
of life that I'm not sure we'll ever see
again maybe we we will I don't know well
I mean when they came out I posted on
Twitter that
um I thought the mandates were
unconstitutional I got into lots of
arguments with that
um I told people that they shouldn't
listen to uh
media personalities and that they should
concern themselves with dealing with
their doctor rather than anybody else
there are people that are
immunocompromised that would have
benefited from that and then there are
people for example that had a high heart
rate like my friend's mother when she
went to go get vaccinated she went to
her doctor first and they said wait a
minute ma'am you have very high blood
pressure this is dangerous let's lower
your blood pressure first then that's
what happened and she was on our end so
she was one of these people that had to
get vaccinated or lose their job but now
which was crazy right but now in in
court in New York Court that they've uh
overturned like I just saw that they're
reinstating all well before we before we
say that that's not actually happening
yet there's been an appeal filed by the
mayor so the mayor is going to appeal it
because I saw that they were going to
try to pay them some bags no no just for
the people that are watching at home
they fought the 911 First Responders for
20 years you think that they're going to
get their pockets tapped by a handful of
people no the city is ruthless okay
these people are monsters these are
they're animals like when I say that my
friend Eton Edwards who was on Fox on
NBC he was on all these companies
um he's a survival expert and when he
went down and was helping to pull people
out of the rubble on 911 he was in a
full hazmat suit Kev who told me he was
like and he was yelling at the police
officials he's like look dude why are
you giving these firefighters and cops
these [ __ ] [ __ ] breathers why are you
giving them like a [ __ ] n95 that
doesn't help in there's radioactive
chemicals in there like there's actual
911 syndrome now people have this
corrosive chemical in their lungs
because they don't actually have a
conversation about what was in those
floors those buildings yeah bureaucracy
of the politics of it I mean I think
that's a big uh Jon Stewart's a big
proponent of trying to get help to I
mean if people maybe have seen some of
the viral moments of John screaming at
politicians like but yeah it's crazy
it's crazy if like you can't take care
of the people the biggest tragedy in the
history of our country really you know I
mean how about this we went on a
different podcast American cholo and we
brought up the fact that there are a lot
of deported veterans and I have a lot of
my friends that don't have papers that
say that they're United States citizen
but they have papers that say their
United States Marine and that they
served in Iraq and Afghanistan and these
guys aren't being deported because
they're murderers or rapists camp
they're being deported because they
[ __ ] up some paperwork or because they
had a drug addiction and my stance is
regardless of how you feel about
immigration how dare you tell a person
who stood a post and supposedly served
this country for your freedom whether
you believe that or not because some
people say oh it was all oil Wars
regardless this man stood post and if
you can throw him out so easily and you
can throw his benefits out right if his
missing hand doesn't mean anything then
you're missing I don't mean nothing
Congressman if you don't if his missing
fingers and his missing jaw don't mean
nothing then your missing legs don't
mean nothing Senator that's the truth
whether it's democrat or republican you
have to pay attention to the people that
have bled for this nation because
Empires don't die because they lose a
war we haven't won a war since World War
II they die because people stop
believing in them that's real that's I
mean that's crazy to say out loud we
have not won I mean we did not win the
Afghanistan war we did not win Vietnam
I mean we tied Korea it was it was a
wash it was a wash all right you can
have that yeah we'll take this yeah
hey guys we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our good folks over at
bluechoo.com that's right listen you
gotta go to Bluetooth right now sign up
for uh Bluetooth with the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get your first
month for free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient adds Viagra Ana Cialis but in
a chewable form that's right you pop the
blue shoe chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ] Raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like are you
looking and he does the [ __ ]
this is gonna be your dick it's gonna be
like ryu's [ __ ] uppercut you know
what I'm saying God bless whoever's on
the receiving end of that consensually
of course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your doorstep in discreet packaging
no awkward doctor's visits all right
it's all online you don't have to worry
about going and sitting in a waiting
room and be like hey Doc uh my dick I
could use a little a pep in my step and
then it's awkward you gotta look at this
old [ __ ] talking about your dick he
might ask you to pull it out who [ __ ]
knows what's going on at Bluetooth none
of that's happening boochu.com and they
also got the new brand new
a mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know I mean get the
mint chewable yeah your wife will thank
you your girlfriend no thank you your
boyfriend will thank you whatever the
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you as
long as it's legal all right let's get
back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it that is that is wild to think man
like for you do you feel like
um
your messaging your music like do you
feel like you're a voice that is needed
now more than ever because there's so
much muck in the world there's so much
especially on the hip-hop side man like
I mean I feel like
we're missing a mortal technique right
now I mean thank God that I'm coming out
with a new record right yes thank God
that I'm working on new music so I I've
definitely been doing that and also
um I guess I'll just come out and say it
since I've been saying in another
podcast
um I do some screenwriting now I do like
fixing scripts and people contact me for
stuff and
um it's been an incredible experience
the only problem with that Kev is that
when I do writing people can edit the
joke if it's too ruthless or something
right like why this is the point this is
why you people have me in the [ __ ]
room yeah you can write the type of [ __ ]
that people like oh my god what the hell
but that's just to a limit I think with
music with hip-hop I'm able to do that
even more so than I ever was before and
then of course you know I started this
journey
um with my brother Southpaw who used to
work for Puff Daddy so he knew a lot
about kind of the the studio environment
he had set up the pro tools for Daddy's
house
so I guess for me one of the best parts
about kind of growing with this culture
has been to always stay true to the
ideals that it first started we're not
here to try to convince people of what
it is we're here to offer you these
facts that you have not been presented
before you haven't even seen the
evidence you're basing your opinion on
what you've been shown but not
everything else I think it's hard to
divorce people from their politics Kev
it is man because the politics is not
just politics it's their entire circle
of friends the echo chamber that comes
with it the family that they're with
it's who you follow on Instagram and
telling the algorithms telling people to
leave your family yeah it's crazy so
people have gotten to a point where it
doesn't matter the morality of the
person that's been assigned to it as
long as it's their side they can find a
reason to not hold that person to the
same standards as they would somebody
else and at that point it's just so
politicized that there's no moral left
in it and it's not like there's a moral
compass there's just like oh okay
imagine if your lawyer your son goes to
to trial for murder right right the best
lawyer in the world
has a 14 year old wife
and you're like
dude he's the best lawyer in the world
though right what are we doing here
that's where we are in politics and you
know we don't even have a shared history
you saw the governor of Florida get up
and say hey it's wrong
we have stolen land right yeah it's
great I was going to ask you man because
we're probably it's funny because I
remember as a kid how much people did
not [ __ ] with George W bush at a certain
point I remember like that Michael Moore
[ __ ] came out uh
I forget that it was a bowling 911 or
some [ __ ] uh that the the first
documentary that kind of like
was like kind of political people
weren't [ __ ] with bush but then there
was people who were loving Bush but
now man this [ __ ] is so crazily divided
and I feel like the pendulum on each
side has swung so
extreme that like if somebody like you
said if somebody is just a a normal
Common Sense human being like you said
like I feel like I probably I grew up
like a Democrat right but I feel like
more and more I'm just like maybe I'm
just like an independent or uh a
Libertarian I don't know because like
you said I'm also very pro-second
Amendment um but nowadays man it's like
everybody and it's probably always been
like this but it's a little bit more
magnified these days because of social
media but I just feel like we're in this
like weird rut as a country where like
everybody is just so standing on
whatever this island is and whatever
this Island's going for at the time you
have to align with all of it or you're
on you're over there like I would like I
would have the truth is it you bring up
a good point Democrats have never fought
against Republicans as hard as they
fought against the left wing of their
own party that's the god that's the
God's honest truth and a lot of people
that I personally know that started
getting closer to trumpism and to Maga
and I I listen this is the god listen if
you if your feelings get hurt I I'm not
here to cuddle you a lot of those people
were actually Bernie Sanders supporters
and they feel and they feel that the
Democratic party is more corrupt than
the Republicans Bernie over two two
times but they they feel like more
corrupt I think when we talk about the
war being involved in it that's one
thing where I have to draw a line
because Republicans can't hide behind
Trump's skirt simply because he didn't
start any new Wars he dropped a MOAB on
Afghanistan and after the first 18
months of his presidency please look it
up the drone strikes started again
however that doesn't excuse them pushing
Democrats to a point where they had to
have Mr Obama commit a series of war
crimes because the drone strikes that he
was uh sending out to Afghanistan were
based on metadata that's why they gave
him the name the Drone Ranger right
because those metadatas the metadata
literally means a phone or a device so
you're basing it on a phone that this
person right which is why when they
exposed the rate of the drone strikes
they found out that it was over 80 and
90 percent the wrong person that they
hid and why did we have to learn that
through Wikileaks that's just unfair to
the people themselves who pay taxes into
a system where they believed they were
actually fighting a war against people
trying to kill us whereas we knocked
over a country that had nothing to do
with 9 11. nothing and then when we get
really into detail remember the the that
lady Sarah Palin and everybody was
making fun of her because she couldn't
answer what the Bush Doctrine was listen
the Bush Doctrine ladies and gentlemen
is US knocking over countries in the
Middle East that don't follow our
hegemonic view of the region tell me
that Mr Obama didn't do that once Mr
Bush got out of office he did the same
thing that's the issue that we're facing
we're facing the nakedness of the Empire
The Mask taken off the revealing of the
fact that we don't actually care if a
place is democratic or communist or any
of these things as long as you back the
United States of America will give you a
pass in the same way that I see these
horrible things that the arguments that
are happening online in between uh black
people and Jewish people over what's
transpired Kanye and everything and I
say the sad part is that if you look at
actual conservatives that have said
horrible things about Jewish people
they're not they're better they're not
touched but it's also because they
supported the state of Israel in the
same sentence so this complicates the
case very much and I think it's actually
damaged the relationship that black and
Jewish people have because they feel
like they've been singled out and the
other group feels like they've been
singled out I think that more than ever
needs some kind of healing some kind of
reciprocity to understand because you
have an entire group of people who say
well there's different consequences for
US versus that and that makes people
feel like their lives aren't worth the
same right right and I think on the
other end you have a group of people who
have felt that they've been persecuted
in Europe and now they're persecuted
here and therefore high up on end and
whether you agree with anything the man
said or not you have legitimate divide
in the community now where people are
arguing that didn't even have a problem
Consciousness to argue before so like
you said the political lines are already
kind of drawn there for a person if they
wanted to crawl into that trench to then
feel comfortable with because they don't
have to listen to an opposing opinion
like you said there's a lot of echo
Chambers there's a lot of places where
people just hear something repeated they
don't want to hear the truth they don't
want to say okay well Republicans have
actually never shrunken the size of
government that Democrats have committed
war crimes in the past two two decades
these are not comfortable topics but
they're true and that's the reason why I
guess people love my music because I
give it to both sides because I don't
pull punches and because when it comes
down to it I'm not just independent in
terms of the music but I try to be
independent here in front of the
politics because I realize what's
actually happened as a case of this now
we could take subject matters
independently right like immigration
abortion and we can discuss all these
things of course but with that comes
historical Nuance right when people say
oh immigrants who got everything and I'm
like well why don't you look up the
Homestead Act or the Dawes Act where
this government gave millions of acres
to White settlers that just came off a
boat from somewhere because you wanted
indigenous people to be replaced we hear
a lot from the far right about a white
replacement Theory but let's have a
conversation about indigenous
replacement practice
cultural reality of that yeah so I think
in many ways it's not that people are
angry at socialism Kev they're mad that
only rich people have been able to use
it that they got billions of dollars of
bailouts and that nobody who lost their
home gun you always say like socialism
like obviously I think like I was a
Bernie supporter I donated to this
campaign I loved Bernie I just loved him
because he was the most consistent
politician I had ever seen at least it
was very honest in the sense that you
know when you heard that Hillary Clinton
calling him a violent misogynist
everyone was scratching their head like
you talk about your husband you talk
about Bernie she's wild what are we
doing here she's she's yeah Jesus Christ
but I think Hillary was crazy but I
think that that that having a
conversation
um
just shows you how many people were
understanding that yes we do have
socialism in this country socialism for
the rich and I'll give you an example
the the the the first kind of economic
experiment that people learn in this
country is a lemonade stand for little
kids right what up y'all we gotta stop
the interview real quick tell you about
our good friends at my bookie that's
right man my bookie is where you want to
get this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview let me
show you why this is deceptive and part
of the reason capitalism is failing you
the little kid is out there selling
Dollar Glasses of lemonade
you haven't bought the lemons kid your
mommy did just like the government buys
stuff for these big companies you didn't
buy the knife that you cut the lemons
with a matter of fact you probably
didn't even cut the lemons you don't own
the pitcher you don't own the house you
never paid the water bill you didn't
bring the table outside right and you're
not going to clean everything up when
it's over so you are the exemplifying
precise example of what the American
corporation does which is live off the
welfare of the state to make money for
itself and meanwhile you're fighting
imaginary communism when it's just
corporatism you don't even have to
imagine Illuminati imagine the corporate
Board of Kmart they'll give you as much
access to what they're talking about as
Illuminati will you're not invited into
that boardroom you're not invited into
the boardroom where they say oh we can't
sell these products because they have
high fructose corn syrup I just came
back from a tour in Europe they're at
they don't even sell American Products
there because they say that they cause
cancer and they're crazy and another
thing you could buy a doctor just as
easily as you can buy a politician
ladies and gentlemen which is what the
FDA does here in this country so I'm
sorry that I got just bad news I feel
like that's kind of what happened with
the entire covet [ __ ] it was like the
doctors who would say hey it's not for
everybody or if they got silenced or
they got taken off Twitter I know there
was uh one uh guy who was a writer he
was just on Joe Rogan recently who he
actually sued Twitter
um because they took him off Twitter
they banned him he's like a writer uh
because he pretty much spoke out against
the vaccine just saying hey guys it
doesn't cure it they deleted his tweet
they banned him
and he sued him because he's that's kind
of a part of his living as a writer and
he they had to reinstate him and then
they had to pay him money right well I
mean his his premise was and I think I
know exactly who you're talking about he
said listen if
I'm not an anti-vaxxer I I I'm for polio
for all these other things yeah I got
the I got the first round but but let me
just say honestly the thing that he
brought up that's incredibly important
that he should never have been punished
for
he said that it's technically not a
vaccine because if you take it then you
shouldn't get the virus if you can still
get the virus but for example what they
decided to Rebrand and say well it's not
that you don't get the virus is that you
get a must much lesser effect but that's
something I said initially exactly so
that's kind of the back foot that they
fell on and that's kind of like what I
get when I argue with people and they
want to try to convert me to something
and then I bashed them so hard and then
they're on the back foot saying oh both
sides are corrupt no that's where you
should have started from Brother that's
not the position you Retreat to so when
I discuss these things in terms of like
the covet response that was a big reason
why we did the rebel Army runs we defied
the lockdowns not out of gratuity not
just to be on IG like oh we're out here
when they said we couldn't be that's not
Rebellion that's not revolutionariness
that's just you trying to be a troll for
IG we actually went out there and when
we were moving this food and these
products the police stopped me before
and they said what do you do doing and I
said I've become the food program for
the grant houses I'm feeding these
people that's what I'm supposed to do
isn't it and the guy's like you're
wearing like a a
you're wearing a vest and you have a
scanner right I said that's for on my
own personal amusement and he's like
what are you doing with that today I
said I don't feel like discussing my day
officer but I'm going to be here and I'm
going to continue to support these
people in my community oh by the way
you're from the 26th Precinct right
you're one of Captain Alex's boys what
if she found out that you were trying to
cut off the food program out of that de
Blasio canceled you know the Blasio the
one that you hate right yeah I know how
to talk to people right so the guy's
like man you can either stop me from
doing what I'm supposed to do brother or
you can make sure that we get through to
these people and I'm going to be real
they folded not in like a oh no like no
they folded like wow I see your point
cool so we were out there and through
all the lockdowns we started this
program in March of 2020.
so when this just started because they
really announced the pandemic in like
February so late March early April was
when we started and it was me and this
one tiny little Dominican girl wow and
her boyfriend would help now and then
but that's what it was so I tell people
listen
you're gonna get yelled at you're going
to have people disagree with you it's
okay what the purpose is is not to force
your ideas on other people you let them
come to them naturally you present other
arguments and you give them the ability
to make that decision 100 I think too
many too many times like we were just
talking about people expect to be able
to change someone's mind immediately and
people don't work like that I mean if
you tell people not to do something it's
a perfect way to get them to try to do
something that's how human beings are
wired yeah and if you don't touch the
Apple if you tell people they have to do
something you're right then they don't
want to do it well wait a minute right
wait a minute I have to do it it's my
body what the [ __ ] as opposed to like
hey here's what here's the facts
figure it out right 100 man but I mean I
look my mom is a two-time cancer
survivor so I took it very seriously of
course like I mean I I was asked away
from it you know yeah yeah she she was
in a nursing home man so it was
obviously a real it's a real thing I
just think that like there was just so
much misinformation that was being fed
it was on TV every day it was the
fear-mongering normal [ __ ] that it's
been happening on the media forever and
I feel like so many of the voices that
were just kind of giving uh other
alternative points and actual facts
about the vaccine were silenced and it
was just like it just like I feel like
two two years fast forward a lot of that
is kind of like yeah well maybe if you
did catch covid you really didn't need
to get the vaccine if you're a healthy
person and you got it your antibodies
are going to be stronger and you you
know if you're a younger male you don't
have to worry about the risk of
myocarditis and all this but if you are
a young person and you happen to have
anything like a breathing issue or
asthma then you're much more likely to
suffer some of the worst consequences
right it's like it just depends on your
like that but that's my whole point why
I told people hey don't listen to come
up with shock come up go and go to your
doctor and get checked out and say hey
is it okay if I do this or is this wrong
and I think what the main issue that I
saw happen with so many people is that a
one people weren't empathetic towards
people who thought they really needed it
and the people who were who were in need
of it had no empathy towards the people
that were on some like holistic medicine
stuff which is something that I'm I'm
down with but at the same time it's like
okay you're gonna tell me that now
because this person wore a mask that
they're propagating fascism like okay I
had an argument with a dude like a
friend of mine who's a prominent guy in
the anti-max world and I said listen
brother
they didn't take your freedom this time
they already had it when you butchered
one million Iraqis a country that had
nothing to do with 9 11. they already
got your freedom when they sent you to
Afghanistan they already got your
freedom right when they had you bomb
Libya and open a slave market there they
already got your freedom what they
wanted now with this was something
totally different they didn't need to
put a microchip in the vaccine you
already got the microchip walking around
with this it's in your pocket that's why
it's telling everybody but what they did
do is that exposed something even
crazier that Adam Smith and Karl Marx
even though they're diametrically
opposed sides of Communism and
capitalism were both right there's only
two classes the middle class is a farce
right and that's what covid taught you
because you could be have a nice house
Kev you have a nice car a job but you're
worth negative six hundred thousand
dollars and a lot of you lost your homes
during that time and you realized oh no
there are only two classes there's the
working class and they're the people who
control the means of production and if
you're not one of these two people
then you think you're one in the middle
you're not really one in the middle
you're here see these people know who
the [ __ ] they are they don't pay taxes
their corporation doesn't pay taxes if
people want to look up any example of
that there's a famous woman from New
York called Leona Helmsley who owned the
Helmsley building and she got in trouble
because for years she paid no taxes like
all major corporations yeah I mean
Google doesn't pay I mean none of these
people pay taxes but she went out and
said in the media in the New York Times
only little people pay taxes and they
had to get her because this is such a
[ __ ] uproar in New York they were
like little people like you mean Working
Class People because a capitalist system
creates food and shelter as Commodities
so you're forced to work a 40-hour work
week instead of venturing to things you
would possibly like the fact that look
if I get a a an album done and I pay the
record label back in a traditional
scenario I don't even keep the
intellectual property that's crazy if I
if I get a bank alone for anything else
and I pay the loan back I own the car
it's your car is mine everything the
problem is this now people bring up is
the house really yours because if you
don't pay those property taxes that
equal the equivalent of the house
payment over 50 years they take the
house do you ever stop paying for it
also like how many people actually
finish the 30-year mortgage before they
they move on to the next thing
it's like ever it's like a rotation of
of [ __ ] for sure man hey we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our partners at Odd Socks our
presenting sponsor here at the
bootlegate podcast listen Christmas time
is approaching faster than you think I
mean we're like [ __ ] a month and a
half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get
some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy literally the most
comfortable sock in the world I'm
holding the [ __ ] sock right now you
can save 20 off plus they got boxers now
baby all right go to odd
socksofficial.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at Odd Socks and the podcast at
the same [ __ ] time let's get back to
the interview well listen uh you say you
you're you're dropping new music yeah um
we got the the new website
immortaltechnique.com I actually had to
sue for it
um I had an anonymous squatter that was
trying to charge me twenty thousand
dollars for it so a hell of a hustle I
know a lot of I know that there's a lot
of people doing that they just buy
websites and they my lawyer said no no
no we've reached out to this person and
they said no no no we'll put the price
up so he goes we're gonna Sue and we're
gonna demand that they show up to court
and they didn't show it I showed up with
my best suit on I was walking there like
I always made the joke that I was
walking like Malcolm and Spike Lee was
not like this uh I was walking right to
court like what is it no show okay thank
you the website's mine for 175 [ __ ] you
people that tried to rob me but now
we're live at Mortal technique.com you
can get the website you can get tour
dates and you can contact us at the
rebel Army runs if you want to make a
tax uh deductible donation to charity
are you going to the streaming services
are you doing because you know there's
there's a lot of people who have kind of
it's an unfair system I feel like in
terms of like if if you have like a
thousand fans you should be able to make
real money off your music as opposed to
making pennies off your streams and I
know a lot of people are just going
straight to Consumers these days whether
it's like dropping the CD dropping a
download on your website doing the vinyl
thing like how are you gonna drop it I
guess traditionally in 2022 ways like on
Spotify on iTunes and all that or are
you going to do other stuff
um I'm still looking at that but I mean
I think either way presents its own
challenges I know that when I release a
record
that I have to campaign the album right
it's not just like throwing it against
the wall
I think also the fact that I've spent so
much time working on this album the
Middle Passage that it's incredibly
important the fact that it has the
subject matter of pretty much an African
genocide in that sense
um I don't have the n-word anywhere on
the record wow it is one of the most
scholastically put forth uh
examples of my work and also I'm going
to show you that even without using
certain words I can be even more
ruthless more brutal more painful more
gut-wrenching more metaphorically and
similarly driven
wretchedness that will make you vomit
blood than I did before and I'm still
that guy and I'm still here I'm still
down with the immigrants I'm still down
with the Second Amendment I'm still down
with educating my people about how to
grow food independently and you know I
appreciate any platform that I'm given
the ability to come and speak brother
yeah you're a legend I'm curious earlier
you said recipes Chris Dorner now his
his I feel like his story
and his Manifesto I feel like that's
such an interesting
uh
topic that doesn't get brought up enough
because I do feel like
it's kind of like depending on your
perspective on it I mean obviously
nobody should ever condone like people
dying and stuff but but I I always was
thinking in my head I was like man I
wonder if anybody will ever tackle that
topic from like a conceptual way through
hip-hop whether it's a record whether
it's telling that story maybe I'll keep
you in the game I can't throw it for you
cat but we definitely did bring
something up like that on the record I
appreciate you saying that yeah because
I feel like you would be the guy to do
it I'm the guy that did it already Okay
it's coming out but I mean like I said
we don't do gratuitous violence we talk
about what it is in terms of what that
exposes right the fact that people were
so scared of him that they decided to
shoot other people that weren't even him
the fact that they were like okay you
actually have documented files and we
heard testimony from the city council
and so many racist things they said
Chris Dorner allegedly had documents and
recordings of high-level people in the
LAPD and government saying things that
were probably just as bad if not worse
so I think that there's a lot of sketch
that's around him there's other people
in that are in my proximity that I've
had a similar experience with that I'll
say okay I went to Penn State University
right and around the same time when the
sexual molestation allegations were
going on Sandusky that other coaches
knew there was a district attorney who
was the district attorney in my case as
a matter of fact when I went to prison
um his name was Ray greekar and he was
investigating the Sandusky stuff and
guess what he was disappeared they found
his his he's still going he was he was
he was declared missing like and he's
declared dead you can look his name up
Ray Greek card
g-r-i-c-a-r and they found his laptop
missing a hard drive in a [ __ ] lake
or like in a river like a little stream
like a mile away from his house so this
guy who was investigating who could have
possibly covered up the rape allegations
gave whoever it was cover enough for
them to blame only the people who got
caught and none of the giant donors from
Penn State who part took another Circle
too yeah hey man I'm not going to stop
talking about this so if something
happens to me we all know what it is
that shit's crazy you know what man I do
feel like though we are in a
[Music]
I mean even if it doesn't really matter
I do think that nowadays
people are a little bit more skeptical
of the information they're given and
they'll they try to dig in a little bit
under the surface a little bit more than
than you know I feel like that's
obviously in the internet's kind of
changed a lot of just the way people
think and hopefully like you said
hopefully people can snap out of this
[ __ ] weird
tribal like extreme I'm over here or I'm
over here and if you don't agree with me
on this but you agree with me on 10
other things but you don't agree with me
on this it's [ __ ] you you're over there
it's like well I think the the primary
basis I have to say is that I'm willing
to agree with
um anybody or be able to have that
disagreements as long as those
disagreements don't infringe on my
Humanity I'm almost like trying to take
away my humanity and I think what you
also bring up is important to say for
all those people that are talking about
a civil war just remember the only
winners of a Civil War in the United
States will be China and Russia you'll
hand them the planet good luck though
that's how we're going to end the
interview
[Music]